jeune lycéen pères mères de familles
retraités ils étaient près de 3000 à
clamer leur opposition au projet de loi
de mariage puces dans les rues de
versailles mardi soir pourtant le
scénario semble écrit d'avancé à
l'assemblée nationale la majorité veut
tout faire pour faire voter le texte
adopté par le sénat le gouvernement a
beau lui a fait verser le programme de
l'assemblée nationale on pouvoir passer
en force dès cette semaine
le gouvernement emploiera la technique
de l'ordonance le gouvernement fait
corps le projet de loi dans sa dernière
ligne droite aujourd'hui avec l'examen
en seconde lecture par les députés mais
les manifestants continuent de faire
monter la pression
je propose soit trop tard en fait la
manifestation ne font que commencer je
pense puisqu'en fait viard une montée en
puissance importante
ce que nous souhaitons c'est avoir des
missions j'irai partout
c'est pour cela que nous avons fait ses
valises à sion aujourd'hui à versailles
revenons au plus proche des citoyens 58%
des français sont opposés à l'adoption
pour les couples homosexuels
les opposants à la loi taubira
continuent de réclamer un référendum
moi c'est une femme aujourd'hui celle
des démocraties étudiants après sur la
loi elle-même dit maria c'est le concept
sont la ville qui est juste différente
et c'est vrai qu'on ait deux neveux
population on se comprend juste pas mais
c'est pas parce qu'on ne comprend pas
qu'on a pas loin d'en discuter
et aujourd'hui on nous refuse à
discussion et c'est ça qui me choque
profondément
dans la soirée quelques interpellations
ont eu lieu devant la préfecture de
versailles
les anti mariage pour tous que compte
pas s'arrêter là de nouvelles
manifestations sont prévues dans les
prochains jours dont un grand
rassemblement à paris le 21 avril